you
what happened at the beginning of
everything this question has preoccupied
scientists and philosophers for
centuries but now new data from a
telescope in Antarctica may be giving us
the answer the confirmation that
physicists have long been looking for
that the universe rapidly expanded right
after the Big Bang a theory called
cosmic inflation physicists believed
that in the first billionth of a
trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second of the universe's
life it underwent a mind-bogglingly
rapid expansion but finding evidence for
this is fiendishly hard researchers must
look in the very fabric of space-time
for clues according to Einstein when
something really violent happens like
the rapid expansion of the universe
after the Big Bang it creates ripples in
space-time he called these ripples
gravitational waves as gravitational
waves passed through the universe they
compress and expand space finding the
very first gravitational waves would
tell us about the birth of the universe
if only we could see them the expanding
universe would have stretched these
primordial waves so much that today the
distortions they caused would be
absolutely miniscule so how on earth or
in space are we supposed to find them
imagine a beach the waves roll in and as
they do they churn up the sand mixing
and distorting it the waves recede with
the tide but they leave behind an
imprint ripples in the sand the universe
isn't covered in sand in fact it's
mostly nothing but one thing it is full
of is radiation the cosmic microwave
background the cosmic microwave
background is the afterglow of the Big
Bang and it is everywhere
perhaps this radiation could hold an
imprint of gravitational waves to find
out a team led by the Center for
Astrophysics in Massachusetts built
super-sensitive radiation detectors they
took them to the South Pole installed
them in a telescope and started looking
for ripples in the sand nine years of
painstaking search and analysis later
and they found something swirling
patterns in the cosmic microwave
background created they say by
gravitational waves from the beginning
of the universe this is the most direct
evidence ever for the existence of
gravitational waves as predicted by
general relativity almost a hundred
years ago but more than that it is the
most convincing evidence yet for
inflation it seems that finally
scientists can claim to understand the
very earliest moments of the universe
[Music]
[Music]
you